>>> UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW, JURY
SELECTION IN THE AASHWARI MURDER
TRIAL.
ARBERY IS THE 25-YEAR-OLD MAN
CHASED DOWN AND SHOT TO DEATH
WHILE JOGGING IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
NEAR BRUNSWICK, GEORGIA.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS HAPPENED
MONTHS BEFORE THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FLOYD, AND IT HAS BEEN
PART OF THE BROADER DISCUSSION
AND PROTESTS FOCUSED ON RACIAL
JUSTICE.
THREE WHITE MEN ARE CHARGED WITH
ARBERY'S KILLING.
GREGORY McMICHAEL, HIS SON
TRAVIS AND THEIR NEIGHBOR
WILLIAM BRYAN, ALL THREE HAVE
PLEADED NOT GUILTY TO CHARGES OF
MALICE AND FELONY MURDER ALONG
WITH OTHER CHARGES.
NOW, THIS CASE LINGERED FOR
MONTHS BEFORE ANYONE WAS
ARRESTED.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN UNTIL VIDEO
OF THE DEADLY ENCOUNTER
SURFATESED, SO THE KILLING
HAPPENED IN FEBRUARY.
THE VIDEO SURFACED IN MAY, AND
IT WAS AFTER THAT WHEN PEOPLE
WERE ARRESTED.
CNN'S MARTIN SAVIDGE HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT JURY
SELECTION AND HOW LONG THIS IS
EXPECTED TO TAKE, MARTIN?
>> Reporter: WELL, ANAA, IT'S
VERY COMPLICATED AND THAT VIDEO
PLAYS INTO IF BECAUSE REMEMBER
THE CASE OF DEREK CHAUVIN IN THE
DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD.
THERE WAS VIDEO THAT SHOWED HOW
GEORGE FLOYD DIED.
THERE IS VIDEO.
WE KNOW HOW AHMAUD ARBERY DIED.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT WERE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND THAT DEATH,
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WILL MAKE THE
FINAL DECISION ON THAT IS THE
JURY, AND THAT'S WHY JURY
SELECTION IS SO CRITICAL.
ABOUT A THOUSAND JURY SUMMONS
WERE SENT OUT IN GLEN COUNTY,
NOT A BIG COUNTY SO 1 IN 85
PEOPLE RECEIVED ONE OF THOSE
SUMMONS.
THE FIRST 600 PEOPLE SHOWING UP
TODAY, AND THAT PROCESS IS MADE
MORE COMPLICATED BY THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE THREE DEFENDANTS,
AND EACH UP OF THOSE DEFENDANTS
HAS TWO ATTORNEYS AND ON TOP OF
THAT YOU HAVE THE PROSECUTION
AND THE JUDGE THAT WILL ALL
WEIGH INTO THE OVERALL MAKEUP OF
WHAT THIS JURY WILL LOOK LIKE,
AND THERE ARE CONCERNS.
WANDA COOPER JONES, AHMAUD
ARBERY MOTHER HAS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE JURY AND ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THAT VIDEO.
>> I THINK WITHOUT THAT VIDEO WE
WOULDN'T HAVE AN ARREST, BUT I
THANK GOD THAT THE VIDEO CAME
AND WE GOT ARRESTS, AND NOW
WE -- WE'RE HERE TO SELECT THE
JURY TO GET JUSTICE FOR AHMAUD.
THERE WERE LOTS OF
MISCOMMUNICATIONS ON WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET THE RIGHT PLACE IN THE
RIGHT PLACE TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION.
>> SELECTING THAT JURY COULD
TAKE TWO WEEKS, SOME SUGGEST
MAYBE EVEN TWO AND A HALF WEEKS.
>> MARTIN SAVIDGE, THANK YOU.
>> LET'S GET PERSPECTIVE FROM
AREVA MARTIN.
BOTH THE DEFENSE AND ARBERY'S
FAMILY ARE EXPRESSING DERN ABOUT
WHETHER A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
JURY CAN BE SEATED IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
COMPLICATED, ANA.
WE KNOW IN THE HIGH-PROFILE
CASES IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
FIND PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T HEARD
ABOUT THE CASE, HAVEN'T READ
ABOUT THE CASE, HAVEN'T SEEN THE
EXTENSIVE MEDIA, BUT THIS CASE
IS MORE COMPLICATED THAN THE
TYPICAL HIGH-PROFILE CASE
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE THE
DISTURBING VIDEO OF THE SHOOTING
OF AHMAUD ARBERY, WE ALSO HAVE
THE PROSECUTION OF THE ORIGINAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
WE HAVE THAT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WHO PLAYED KNAVETISM TOWARDS ONE
OF THE DEFENDANTS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY WORKED, GREGORY
McMICHAEL, WHO HAD ACTUALLY
WORKED IN HER OFFICE.
THAT DELAYED THE ACTUAL
INDICTMENT OF THESE THREE
DEFENDANTS, AND IT WASN'T, AS
YOU SAID IN THE OPENING UNTIL
THERE WAS A HUGE PUBLIC OUTCRY
AND THE RELEASE OF THAT
VIDEOTAPE THAT WE ACTUALLY SAW
ANY KIND OF ACTION TAKEN WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE DEFENDANTS, SO
I THINK ALL OF THOSE ISSUES ARE
GOING TO COME INTO PLAY AS BOTH
SIDES TRY TO PICK IMPARTIAL
JURORS.
>> YOU POINT OUT THE PROSECUTION
HAS CHANGED HANDS MULTIPLE
TIMES.
I THINK THEY ARE ON THE FOURTH
PROSECUTOR, AND, IN IN FACT, IT
WAS THE ORIGINAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JACKIE JOHNSON WHO WAS
INDICTED FOR HER HANDLING OF
THIS CASE, ONE OF THE
DEFENDANTS, GREGORY McMICHAEL
PREVIOUSLY WORKED IN HER OFFICE
AND SHE ALLEGEDLY DIRECTED
POLICE OFFICERS NOT TO ARREST
HIM AND IS ACCUSED OF VIOLATING
HER OATH OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY
BY, QUOTE, SHOWING FAVOR AND
AFFECTION TO GREG McMICHAEL
DURING THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE SHOOTING DEATH OF AHMAUD
ARBERY.
JOHNSON HAS DENIED ANY
WRONGDOING, BUT SPECIFICALLY
THAT ASPECT, HOW DO YOU SEE THAT
PLAYING INTO THIS TRIAL?
>> WELL, I IMAGINE THAT THOSE
JURORS, AND WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
THIS IS A VERY SMALL COMMUNITY,
1 IN 85 PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN A
JURY SUMMONS.
WE KNOW THAT NOT ONLY THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY KNOWS ABOUT AHMAUD
ARBERY'S DEATH AND KNOWS ABOUT
THE INDICTMENT OF THIS
PROSECUTOR AND FOR SOME THAT
WILL SUGGEST A CASE THAT A CRIME
WAS COMMITTED AND THE PROSECUTOR
WAS TRYING TO COVER UP THIS
CRIME.
WE DONE KNOW.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT HAS
ALSO HAD RACIAL TENSION.
ONE OF THE MOTION FILED BY THE
DEFENDANT IS AN EFFORT TO KEEP
OUT THE LICENSE PLATE OF THE
DEFENDANTS BECAUSE IT HAS A
CONFEDERATE FLAG ON IT.
WE'RE ALSO HEARING REPORTS THAT
QUESTIONS ABOUT BLACK LIVES
MATTER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO BLACK LIVES MATTER IS GOING
TO COME INTO THE VOIR DIRE
PROCESS SO RACE IS GOING TO BE A
BIG ISSUE IN THIS CASE, ANA.
REMEMBER,  THERE ARE BEEN
FEDERAL HATE CRIMES CHARGED
AGAINST THESE THREE DEFENDANTS,
SO THIS CASE HAS A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES TO TRAYVON MARTIN,
WHAT WE SAW WITH RESPECT TO
GEORGE ZIMMERMAN, HOW LONG IT
TOOK FOR GEORGE ZIMMERMAN TO BE
CHARGED AND HOW RACIALLY CHARGED
THAT CASE WAS SO WE HAVE TO SEE